due to the internet age and people being
on their phones all the time people have
lost the ability to communicate
effectively with other people and that's
probably not a secret to you at all
you've probably felt the effects of this
in your own life the more you scroll on
your phone the more you become a passive
consumer of content Stuck Inside by
yourself quite naturally you're probably
going to get worse at talking with
people you're probably going to get
worse at coming across as somebody who
is charming and likable and you might be
wondering like okay well in the internet
age what's the point of coming across as
charming and likable why do I need to
care about people pleasing and fair
enough you know I don't think that
people should be overly concerned about
what other people think of them but I do
think that they should be somewhat
concerned because the way the world is
structured right now is most people
don't have Charisma but the people that
do seem to run the world the people with
high Charisma are your worldly well not
all the world leaders the people with
high Charisma are the people you see on
pod casts the people that you see on
your Instagram reels Charisma is in
higher demand than it ever has been
because it's dwindling so I don't know
what your life situation is but I would
argue that there is no life situation
that you could be in where having worse
Charisma than you do now would benefit
you I don't know if you're going into
University for your first semester I
don't know if you're at a new job or a
job that you've been in for your whole
life whether you're starting to date or
whether you're in a relationship maybe
you want to make more friends no matter
what situation you're in if you were to
change one variable that being your
charisma I guarantee you all of those
things would become much easier for you
you could be the most brilliant mind in
the world but if nobody likes you
nobody's going to listen to you nobody's
going to give you a job no one's going
to want to be around you except for your
family if you have low Charisma even
your family will grit their teeth when
they're around you I don't know if
that's entirely true I'm just trying to
create an intro here okay so you've
decided you want to increase your
Charisma while in order to do that you
need to be aware of the three keys to
Charisma the first key is presence
presence is about being fully attentive
and in the moment the most charismatic
people in the world are fully present
when you talk to them they are actually
listening to you there's nobody else in
the room they are not a space cadet
they're not thinking about all of these
other things they have to do or at least
they don't come across that way right
because Charisma is all about perception
it's all about how people perceive you
nothing is less charismatic than when
you're trying to talk to somebody and
they're just on their phone and they
like sometimes make eye contact but
they're really not listening to you
personally you're just like all right
you dude like I don't know what to
do here and at the same time I feel like
we've all talked to people who they are
making eye contact but there just seems
to be like a certain glossiness to their
eyes a wall of separation and you're
like you're looking at me but you're
kind of not responding properly you're
not responding in real time I I don't
actually know if you're listening where
are you so presence naturally is about
being here in this world you are down to
earth so if you want to be perceived as
more present then you kind of have to
actually be present and this is one of
these things that we're going to
discover about Charisma you can do all
these things and pretend to be present
you could be kind of a space cadet
worrying about all these things you have
to do and then just smile and Nod and
aggressively agree and ask some random
question that has nothing to do with
what the person was talking about that's
not being present and people can see
right through that if you want to be
perceived as genuinely present and right
there with somebody then you have to be
genuinely present and be right there
with somebody so how do we do that well
the most obvious thing is tips like
practice mindfulness and don't worry so
much and de-stress and whatever but you
already know all that stuff but I think
the biggest Pitfall to being present and
the biggest reason why almost nobody
seems to be like right there with you
nowadays is well well you guessed it
it's because of screens and I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna get on social media
this whole video because that's all I do
but yeah have you ever noticed that when
you're on your phone all day you know
you're scrolling you kind of arrive at
Instagram and go to Instagram reels and
see what it's cooked up for you today it
almost feels like you're living life on
your heels you show up to a certain
platform because you're kind of bored or
you just do it compulsively maybe you're
procrastinating something and you sort
of hope that whatever platform this is
the algorithm Cooks up something good
that'll make you laugh or something that
you can share with your friends and if
you get into the rabbit hole for long
enough you almost start to melt your
posture becomes even more and more
passive as you just move your thumb and
your brain starts to boil over it's kind
of a strange phenomenon yet it's so
normal but it's the absolute opposite of
being present you are in The Matrix
you're not here you're not you know you
don't actually know that you're sitting
on a chair you're not aware of the
smells around you the sensation of being
alive you're so used to existing in this
passive state that when it comes time to
have a conversation with somebody you're
used to being in a situation where
you're not required to develop a
response yet that is one of the
fundamental keys to being perceived as
charismatic so obviously the solution is
to really pay attention to the way in
which you're using technology I'm not
saying don't watch movies anymore don't
use social media but are you a product
of social media are you the person who's
just consuming it consuming all the ads
being entertained bumping up other
people's views and watch time like my
own or are you using it as a tool are
you using it as something that will give
you value are you starting your own
channel are you posting on social media
for any useful reason when you're
watching movies are you watching any
form of art or are you just putting on a
movie to pass your time because you
don't know what to do with it yourself
you have to ask yourself do I run away
from problems do I have this Escapist
mindset is my head in the clouds or am I
here in this world making a difference
in my own life actively engaged in the
problems actively communicating with
other people in order to be charismatic
you have to come back down to earth and
stay here the second key to Charisma is
power power is the perceived ability to
affect the world around us we are
naturally drawn to people who we
perceive as being powerful it is one of
the most important aspects of Charisma
somebody can be right there with you but
if they don't present themselves with
any sort of dignity then we naturally
don't care as much about their opinion
someone could be right there with you
and have terrible Body Language they
dress very poorly they clearly really
don't like themselves very much you just
generally aren't going to care as much
about their opinion or care to be around
them as much and again that sounds super
shallow but this isn't an issue about
what is morally right I'm not saying
that you shouldn't care about what that
person thinks of you or you shouldn't
care to be around that person or you
shouldn't talk with somebody who doesn't
like themselves very much I'm talking
about Charisma and the components of
Charisma and somebody who does not have
good posture doesn't dress well has low
confidence and appears to have low
self-esteem and a low sense of
self-worth that person is not going to
be perceived as very charismatic so if
you want to become somebody who is
charismatic which I mean if you made it
this far into the video you do you need
to think about how you hold yourself how
you appear to others in the world and as
we've talked about in other videos it's
very hard to fake genuine confidence and
genuine power you might be able to At a
Glance you know someone looks at you and
says okay this person has good posture
he's walking like he's on a mission and
he dresses well but as they start to
have a conversation with you it's very
easy to tell whether somebody is cocky
and just faking it or whether they are
genuinely confident evident and really
have this sense of internal dignity so
in order to generate power in order to
be somebody who feels powerful who is
perceived as powerful and useful and
capable to others you have to be useful
and capable you have to like your life
you have to be proud of yourself you
have to be somebody who feels like
they're doing the right thing somebody
who has a good relationship with
themselves you almost have to generate
this sort of king-like energy a King
when he walks into a room takes up space
he moves slowly he prowls like a lion
the shoulder blades rolling there's a
certain type of movement of power that
almost can't be replicated unless you
actually feel that energy thoroughly
with every fiber of your being and
everybody has felt like that at some
point in their lives when you feel
powerful and when you project power it's
something that has happened as a result
of the way that you've been living your
life it's a result of the active
activities you've been engaging with and
whether or not you've been living your
life according to your own values and
then obviously there is The Superficial
element of it which is very important as
well how do you dress if you have been
taking care of your body you will most
likely look like somebody who is taking
care of their body if you look
physically weak and unhealthy it's
probably because you are physically weak
and unhealthy and people pick up on that
I almost feel like Charisma is sort of a
subconscious filtering mechanism that we
use to assess the health of others it's
almost this tribal mentality where we
say oh this person is good for the
tribe's survival this person is good for
procreation or whatever right there's
almost this like subconscious game going
on where we create value assessments of
others in a blink of an eye we don't
even notice so ask yourself do you exude
power or are you kind of flailing around
you know when you walk around the street
are you looking and seeing if people are
noticing you if you're chronically
single are you going to the grocery
store hoping that there's some cute girl
and you're like checking your Corners to
see if there is one that projects pretty
low value if you are already content you
project this sense of contentment and
satisfaction with your life then you're
not darting around with this pray like
mentality you don't look like a rabbit
who's running across an open plane
hoping that a hawk doesn't swoop down
you just exist you walk around you do
what you got to do yeah you're not
right
I don't know guys before we talk about
both the last key to Charisma and what
it looks like to put that all together I
do want to say that this entire video is
based off of the book The Charisma myth
by Olivia fox cabane or Cobain and a lot
of us have been listening to that on
Audible which is today's video sponsor
because I've been talking about it for a
while I've been telling people to listen
to it develop an opinion about it
because on August 17th at 12 pm PST I'm
gonna be hopping on a live stream with
all of you guys and we're going to be
talking about that audiobook in depth
and for those of you who don't know and
I would be shocked if you didn't audible
is the leading provider of spoken word
entertainment and audiobooks all in one
place every single month they send you
one credit which you can spend on any
audiobook of your choice regardless of
cost and you get to keep that audiobook
forever and audible members also get
access to a rapidly expanding catalog of
audible Originals podcasts and exclusive
series if you use my link in the
description and Below you get a 30 day
free trial and that live stream is
happening less than 30 days from now if
you catch my drift you can also text
better ideas to 500 500 so take
advantage of that offer and I'll see you
on the live stream August 17th okay the
final key to Charisma is warmth you can
be the most powerful person in the world
you can exude this sense of power you
can be very present with somebody but if
they get the vibe that you don't give a
about them and you are extremely
self-absorbed you're very selfish you
are very present but monologuing about
yourself never asking questions never
giving somebody the vibe that you
actually care about them you want the
best for them and that you want the best
for other people you're not going to be
charismatic people are going to see you
as a detriment to their survival they're
not going to want to be around you and
there are tons of people like this I
feel like that's almost the stereotype
of the Wall Street exec dressed in a
nice suit they are right there with you
and they're talking with you they are
mentally Sharp but they don't give a
about you you are an absolute worm
to them and these types of people are
not very charismatic maybe they're
charismatic enough and maybe they kiss
ass to the people who are important to
their uh career advancement but most
people can see through that they're
entirely fake no one really likes them
nobody loves them I think this is the
one that I struggle with the most it's
not because I'm not empathetic I feel
like I'm an extremely empathetic person
but I'm not very good at portraying or
portraying I really need to work on
being like Oh yes no I care about you
anyways yeah so warmth is a weird one I
personally believe that warmth is
something that you can absolutely work
on and it doesn't take much to appear as
a warm person and often I feel like it
just comes down to being proactive with
having an investigatory approach to
conversation like if you never ask
somebody oh how are you doing
oh how are you doing like that's all it
takes is for you to ask how are you
doing right I think anybody can do that
and it goes such a long way into being
perceived as a warm person so many
people just don't get asked how they're
doing
it's tragic and I feel like so many
lives could be saved by people just
asking you know how are you doing and
just listening and somebody being like
you know I'm not doing well and you're
and you can just listen to what they're
saying that's it right that's warmth so
get in the habit of asking people how
they're doing
how's your day going oh why is that oh
that's so sad it doesn't need to be this
whole pity party you can be encouraging
and being encouraging is also a part of
warmth but so is just listening right so
I feel like presence and warmth go hand
in hand being present is I think most of
warmth anyways being present being
actively listening is a lot of what
being warm is and then just asking
questions
um saying I understand
saying like how do you feel about that I
feel like that's basically all it takes
to be perceived as a warm person
nowadays just because it's so rare for
people to ask those types of questions I
feel like most people unless you're a
sociopath are somewhat empathetic but
empathy is something that can be
practiced just by bringing awareness to
the fact that people have their own
lives people are just like you they have
their own struggles and a lot of warmth
and empathy and all that kind of thing
can become cultivated just by spending
less time inside our own heads less time
in isolation more time just being around
a wide range of people and just
listening to people and also don't
underestimate the effectiveness of a
good compliment you know if you're
somebody who gets in the habit of
complimenting people even a fake
compliment is appreciated and welcomed
I've always found that even if you're
like struggling to come up with
something
to uh to compliment somebody on oh
I like your shirt you know it's so
nothing but people usually appreciate
that they're like oh
thank you what the hell so how are you
and I like blah blah blah even if your
compliment makes no sense people tend to
appreciate it okay so let's talk about
bringing this whole thing together what
the hell did I just say what the hell do
all these things mean and what does it
look like when somebody implements
Presence Power and warmth well look no
further than all the charismatic people
in all the movies that we know and love
one of the best displays of Presence
Power and warmth that I've ever seen in
media is Aragorn son of erathorn he is
the perfect example of somebody who
exudes power you know absolute
capability physical prowess king-like
dignity yet when you're talking to
Aragorn he cares about you he cares
about the little ones he cares about his
Hobbits he cares about the world around
him he cares about fighting evil and
being good you don't see him scrolling
on his phone when Frodo's trying to talk
to him what character from a movie or
show or real life do you think is
extremely charismatic because I would
love to know who you think the most
charismatic people are and uh yeah I'm
just curious or am I am I just
expressing warmth am I trying to farm
comments so that the video does better
yes if you are interested in
wasting your life on social media then
follow me instagram.com better ideas I
don't know what to do about that because
I need more followers to
um no I don't